hey guys how's it going today I'm doing
something really really really exciting
I know you guys have probably seen a
million and a half iPhone videos at this
point but guess what here's another one
I just met this fine gentleman behind me
hi my name is Dan Gilbert
I'm a special effects makeup artist in
Los Angeles California
I can't even make this up I met him last
night we did this really cool thing for
another shoot I said what are you doing
tomorrow can you please come over and
destroy my face to see if face ID will
recognize me as whatever it is that
we're gonna do maybe we'll give you some
prosthetic lip enhancements then maybe I
don't know maybe had an accident he
broke your nose can we end up looking
like a zombie is a real question I think
we absolutely can okay cool
well let's get started
so I think the first thing we're gonna
do is we're gonna see what it looks like
if I get Botox in my lips here it is
this is before and I'm gonna show you
guys that I can unlock my phone are you
read well it's already unlocked
okay great that was a great demo turn it
on unlock that's it and if you guys are
wondering what that sound is
that's the time-lapse so what's the
first thing that's happening well I
think we'll start with your lip
injections it's gonna hurt only for like
six or seven hours it's basically gonna
stick down not like a sticker
welcome back he was called a pro Z
transfer of a prostate transfer a
prosthetic transfer it's the walk look
you really have to commit yeah literally
our phone I don't know if you heard that
she's been doing it for the oh you got
some serious lives man oh God
hello how's it going okay I'm just
hurting you zombies I'm used to but
plastics
you didn't go to like the high end these
are my lips now this is what I look like
now we're gonna try to unlock the phone
it unlocked so clearly if I wanted to
get Botox and have this be my new look I
could let's do it again for the camera
ready unlocked did you see that just
just let's get the shot
unlocked uh what should we bust up your
nails and maybe this is a nose job in
common wrong okay here we go
don't go on in now what's this this
smells like glue tell us this a feat to
work so what you're saying is I
shouldn't ever put rubber cement on my
face probably avoid okay it's that's not
how we apply prosthetic makeup yep
No okay that's too close I don't want to
see it like I can see it in the
reflection I'm terrified yeah cuz I
don't know like I can't see anything so
I don't know what's happening so
everything feels very very dramatic like
yes very intense that's my mom
so potentially and nose I mean I might
have just got a nose job like I feel
like this is probably what it looks like
after you get it done right yeah so I've
got a broken nose I've got the lips I'm
just trying to look the best that I can
look will I fell in recognizing unlocked
Oh God oh this look like so layer number
two of fooling the phone have it fooled
it yet this is pretty severe you look
quite a bit different man everybody's
enjoying their food and I know I want to
just fully enjoy it but I'm just so
nervous so I think what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna drink my soup
I can't how this is weird do you love
mommy mmm-hmm
it's so uncomfortable I just wanted to
talk to the lips cause it feels so
strange
I can't even Olive this turn into an
ASMR video so now we are getting like a
side something yeah this would be a
really swollen cheek okay what we're
trying to do now is just sort of build
up to see at what point does face I did
not work I was chatting with that
earlier and he was saying that face ID
actually will learn your face which is
kind of crazy because it is slowly
learning my face every time i unlock my
phone so we're worried that now once I
take this all off that it's gonna forget
what I look like oh wow this looks good
we go to the bar after this name this is
what I need of course we're going pretty
fast on this so excuse my hedges and
thanks guys but we would do this a
little bit more detailed if we were
doing it for a major motion picture this
minor minor motion YouTube video
[Music]
while we're still a lot of guys we're
still unlocking with this look
[Music]
okay so this is what I currently look
like I mean we have I mean I don't think
I look like myself anymore do I
I'm looking at it I'm pressing the
button it unlock yes this is not okay
watch side like you get not straight up
yeah but like I'm holding it low and
still a lot how do you know it's me oh
oh it's it feels like my skin but that's
not my skin Oh guys if you've never felt
this before it's freaking nuts this
looks so real
I don't that's in focus I mean
everything about that that's so good
I think spend a little more time if
we're gonna do this for a major motion
picture but it's for a mind emotion
YouTube video major motion YouTube but
right now we're just trying to unlock my
phone yeah it's like all this just to
see my phone will unlock but can you
believe that have you ever done anything
for such an insignificant reason but I
think it's insignificant I've done worse
things for less significance I'm in it
okay so I'm kind of in shock that this
is still working like my phone is
unlocking with this look like it has now
learned that this is my face so we're
gonna try to intensify it and we're
gonna go fools on the full song
[Music]
this is just regular old KY jelly and I
put a drop of my product it's called
mouth effect this is makeup for inside
your mouth just seeing what you do some
farming we stick your tongue out your
head back ah all right now lick your
teeth click the inside lips button the
corners taste good I can't see her it
looks like one tooth pressure do I need
a new tooth loss
it's so crazy very okay as you can see
it is locked can you see it is a lot
yeah how does it 11 o'clock meant my
goodness but how is this recognizing me
what does that mean does that mean that
this is what I look like
that's my guess yeah okay what's right
again okay just like I'm looking at it I
mean it's got into the eyes but see
there's a video that we worked on that
we can't talk about yet but what we did
is we had like this crazy what was that
it was like a hole that was a foam latex
prosthetic brow piece that was real
severe and it is still somehow
recognized you even the bone structure
was completely there like this is so
good
[Music]
the final look is complete and I to
bring this all to a conclusion the
iPhone still recognizes me like I try I
can unlock my phone just like this but
now we got to take this off the removal
process is it scary it's not scary
okay you're scared huh yeah I guess so I
can't see myself so it's like I don't
even know
[Music]
so this is the real test I'm back to
normal me as much as we can be normal
man that was it was a process to get off
but like it feels fine I feel good yeah
we moose why go slow to save your face
yeah well it's already unlocked I didn't
I mean it's not even exciting it's like
okay cool looking my phone
oh it's unlocked that's it well that's
it
damn thanks so much for being in my
video this was summer so awesome where
can they find you you find me on
instagram and e FX damn I'll put it
right here and I'll put links in the
description thank you guys so much for
watching thanks Dan thank you my
pleasure bye bye guys this is magic it's
magic magic phone I need one a fine one
soon yes December get it next December
thanks great
[Music]